- I would literally be
sitting in English class and
reading the Wine Spectator.
There was just no
controlling my insanity.
("Legendary" by Welshly Arms)
- What if I told you this was
the last Monday
morning of your life?
- [Gary] If you think a lot's
happened in the last 10 years
wait 'til you see what
happens over the next 10 years.
The stakes are enormously high.
And I'm not here fear mongering.
This is just what's happening.
Very honestly, the fact that
you're the crème
de la crème of this,
I assume that the majority of
people in this
room are like yes.
This is the opportunity.
This is where I transition from
a $6 million a year business to
$15 million a year business.
This is when a transition from
$180,000 a year business to a
$2.9 million business.
This is pure opportunity.
The problem is and this is
where everybody defaults into,
they raise their, "Gary,
I don't grow up with this."
Me either, Carl.
(audience laughter)
I didn't grow up
with this either, Carl.
And guess what, Carl?
You didn't grow up
driving and you figured it out.
Understanding the digital
landscape and what our consumers
are doing on it is
now oxygen for businesses.
- Awesome.
- Thank you, darlin'.
Give me a kiss.
- Oh.
- [Gary] Take care.
Thank you for having me.
- I'm glad you had a nap.
- [Gary] Yes.
I did have a nap.
Take care.
Thanks for listening.
Bye guys.
- [Woman] Thank you.
- Thank you for listening.
Bye, thank you.
Take care, man.
Thank you, brother.
Thanks, Michael. Bye.
Let's name it the
2017 small business talk.
DRock.
- [DRock] Gary.
- Yo, yo, yo, yo, yo,
Twitter, Twitter, Twitter.
What's going on?
Good to see you guys.
Morning.
I'm in Louisiana headed to
Vegas for CES.
Got a phone call in a few
minutes but just wanted to jump
onto Twitter and
give you guys some love.
See how you're doing.
Maybe we'll jump on a little
bit and see how we do this.
Hope you guys
are doing super well.
Hope life is good.
And yeah, this
new jacket is fly.
You love it, DRock, right?
- [DRock] Yeah,
it's really nice.
- All good stuff.
Dublin, what's up?
Good to see you.
No, Patriots, no way.
Yeah, anyway.
See ya.
This is for you, my friend.
- Oh, that's very
generous of you.
- [Gary] Take care of yourself.
- Thank you very much, sir.
I appreciate the courtesy.
- [Gary] Happy New Year.
- Alright.
- [Gary] Take care.
- Watch your step.
- Gonna try to add
more context to days.
In the time that I got off the
stage and drove to this airport,
one of our big new scopes for
last year got cut in half from
$2 million to $1 million which
is a problem because the scale
of the dollars was going to
help it be more successful and
one of the CEOs of one of my
successful startups is having
some cultural issues where the
team is struggling
so that's hard core.
And so, very quickly in two
seconds two pretty substantial
fires but you take them in the
micro at the moment and then you
start leveling them
up to a macro. Right?
I take the hit, I absorb it.
Now I'm thinking, I'm pondering,
and now I'm already
strategizing on how to fix it.
I think way too many people
spend too much time dwelling and
they allow something like this
to ruin their day or ruin their
week or ruin their
month or ruin their year.
I think one of the things
I talk about is
having a stomach,
having the
stomach for this game.
This is exactly what I refer to.
I've been around a lot of
executives and a lot of partners
who would use something like
this as a day-ender
as I call it.
I've come to realize how much
of a strength that is of mine of
putting things in
the proper context and
dealing with reality.
You know, when
you're an entrepreneur
you're a firefighter.
Especially if you're
the last line of defense.
It's all on you.
There's no punting it down.
Right now we have a
potential conflict issue of
which account do we go to.
I'm trying to keep
Marcus off as a CEO,
give me a day, give me a day.
The truth is I'm not
accomplishing anything here.
I'm just thinking, I'm trying to
ponder but the quicker you make
actions, the quicker you
can adjust to negativity,
big blows,
medium blows, large blows.
The turnaround speed in
your adjustment to an issue is
usually an unbelievable proxy to
the level of success you'll have
as an entrepreneur.
So you need to start
conditioning yourself for the
emotional war that
entrepreneurship is.
- [DRock] What
are you doing now?
- [Gary] Right now, I'm
answering an AMA for Mogul,
a media site that
I'm an investor in.
Great entrepreneur, she asked me
and it's really not what I want
to be using my time on but
I think you have to come through
for the partnerships you make
and so she doesn't ask often and
so even though it's a tough
week and things of that nature,
I'm doing this AMA on
their site on OnMogul.com
and OnMogul.com
and cranking away at answers,
just trying to get through a
bunch so I can get
through security here.
Somebody asked me about a
time in my life when I was going
through a struggle
and how I got through.
And it made me think about 2005
when I turned 30 and I realized
that my actions were
not backing up my words.
I've said that
a couple of times,
if you have the audacity to
dream you have to make your
actions, you have to do it.
And I had a moment like that.
I was very successful.
I built a huge business and
I would say from 28 to 30
I probably got caught in
to some form of complacency.
We were growing like crazy.
But it was complacent compared
to the ambition that I set out
to accomplish and so from
28 to 30 I was building a
big business, a big wine
e-commerce business.
I was innovating, I was hustling
but I wasn't working
as hard as I am now.
I wasn't doing strategically
smart things that were
gonna allow me to achieve the
professional things
that I wanted.
And I wasn't so
over-capitalizing on my
family time with Lizzie
in return either.
So it wasn't like I was
getting some amazing benefit.
And so, 28 to 30 was an
interesting time for me because
I think that there was so
much success so fast that I got
caught for 24 months of maybe
not hustling as hard and as
smart as I could
and more importantly,
on my 30th birthday I realized
I wasn't gonna
buy the New York Jets.
And that's kind of weirdly okay
as you guys know I
want that but that's okay.
What crushed me
was I was full of shit.
I wasn't putting in the work
at a macro and
micro level to give
me a chance to
buy the New York Jets.
Just got in to Vegas.
Connected in Houston.
Waiting for DRock
to come off the plane.
CES for a couple days, day and a
half and then back on the grind.
Going to Seattle to try and
sign a kid for VaynerSports.
Just did a bunch of email,
the eBay challenge
is out of control.
The 21 Savage moment
in The #AskGaryVee Show
caught people's attention.
So, what's going on.
The ambition I have and the
excitement I have is the process
of trying to buy the New York
Jets versus buying them and so
yeah, I think that era was
interesting to me and so when
I tell you your actions
have to backup your words,
I come from a place of
experience 'cause I lived a
couple years
there where I didn't.
And I know what it tastes like
and I got into a place where
I really spoke myself
from November 14th, 2005
through probably
January 15th, 2005
and then February 20, 2006,
February 2005, I started
Wine Library TV and started
taking the internet
more seriously and
the rest was history.
(light music)
When I was 15 years old,
I signed up for your catalogs
and would post it in my room
like it was a
Pamela Anderson poster.
Macarthur's legitimately one of
the seven or eight stores that
I looked up to
before I built Wine Library.
That's really cool.
That is like...
That is such an amazing time
in my life where I was still in
high school but knew who I was
gonna be and would literally,
this is not a joke, would
literally take the catalog you
guys would send and read it in
the middle of English class.
Like the level of disrespect
that I had for my teachers was
so extreme like
out of a sit-com.
I would literally be
sitting in English class and
reading the Wine Spectator.
There was just no
controlling my insanity.
Just leaving the MediaLink
party and now heading to a
Carbone dinner with
a bunch of friends.
Just hustlin'.
CES is a grind.
18, 19 hour days.
Meeting after meeting, in
Vegas, trying to make it happen.
So, see what's up.
See ya.
(light music)